hey guys I news the seventeenth of
September today my name is Jess McDonald
and you're watching the games button you
sir first up we know halo the master
chief collection is making its way over
text box 1 but it turns out the next gen
hailer train may not stop there 343
industries executive producer dan i have
suggested to video gamer that halo 3
ODST and halo reach my birth make it
onto Microsoft's newest xbox in the
future obviously being that these two
titles don't feature Master Chief they
were left out of the remastered
collection but as far as revamping ODST
and rich goes are you / said I think
enough people have asked about it that
we are thinking about it if waiting for
a hypothetical future where you can play
reach and ODST on your xbox one isn't
really all that attractive to you both
of these games are free on xbox 360
right now if you've got games with gold
en have come out of the woodwork to
explain away the delays of Dragon Age
Inquisition and battlefield hardline and
they put it down to innovation and
polished respectively as far as dragon
age goes EA simply said the release date
was pushed to get rid of bugs but their
reasoning behind battlefield hardlines
delay too early 2015 was a bit more
interesting CEO Andrew Wilson said they
wanted to bring more innovation to the
shooter after receiving feedback from
the beta which included comments like
yeah we like this the whole cops and
criminals thing is cool but we think you
could be doing things more differently
the plan has then been to utilize the
delay to add fan requested features
enhance the single-player story
experience and get the balance right
between innovation and polish last up
sony has been in a bad way for a while
now but now bad has shifted to earth as
the company is bracing for a two-point
14 billion dollar loss that's almost a
whole mojang worth worse for those of
you who haven't been following along
closely with sony's financials that is
quadruple the amount they were expecting
to lose by the end of the current
financial year this marks the sixth time
that Sony's results have been worse than
expected and the first time since
nineteen fifty-eight that they've been
unable to pay an annual dividend to
investors if anybody is wondering how
Sony is doing so poorly when the
PlayStation 4 numbers are all coming
back in the green it's because the
PlayStation division is actually doing
really well it's their smartphone
division which is causing them the
significant chunk of their financial
woes as for your question of the day let
me know how you reckon Sony can pull
themselves out of the red and back
toward breaking even if you're after
more new things we've got stories on
Final Fantasy 15 and Destiny's profits
on site that is it from me today i'll be
back same time and place tomorrow so i
hope to see them